another key characteristic of vampires
is of course the contagious nature of
their condition they can turn others
into vampires Often by sucking their
blood keeping this aspect in mind we can
also find Historical creatures such as
the droger in nor and northern European
folklore in modern parlament the dger is
essentially a kind of zombie the word
basically means ghost but droger is the
physical body of a dead person that has
come back to life for whatever reason
they are often very strong dangerous and
can kill you through crushing or
sometimes even by eating your flesh and
indeed drinking your blood and again
just like both vampires and zombies if
you fall victim to a d you can become
one yourself